okay and you're number three Falconer
okay yeah totally feel you there Baccano
is a game changer it's like I always
tell people it's like if Quentin
Tarantino made an anime exactly I
couldn't have put it better myself
especially the dialogue all right and
number two Fate Zero wait number two
well where would you put it well it's up
there for sure of course it is uh I
would put it behind monster personally
he always had a thing for Johan haha
very funny okay drum roll what does Giga
consider to be the greatest anime of all
time well you know right Demon Slayer
Jesus Christ Ava Eva Evangelion no
Dougan the other Ava got it got it
wait
you've seen Ava right oh no no I I I've
seen it and did you like it no I love it
the World building the religious themes
the weird Freudian undertones the mecca
but not really Mecca designs but out
with a dog it's the ending Evangelion is
the greatest anime ever made up until
episode 25. Logan we're not going there
how could they pivot to 50 minutes of
internal dialogue at the climax of the
story oh my God you entirely missed the
point and I didn't want to spoon feed
views with a child but if that's the
point then why make End of Evangelion
isn't that supposed to be the true
ending you don't do a redo if you've
already stuck the landing and that's
part of the genius of the movie it gives
lunatics like you who demand a proper
ending something to chew on while at the
same time putting out your insecurities
I'm not insecure do you not get that not
every series has to have the perfect
Cinderella story arc did they stick The
Landing or not do you have any
experience with mental illness token
yeah actually I'm a perfectionist
and my wife tells me I'm a chronic
procrastinator Logan that's not okay
explain the plot of Evangelion too
Christ this is the same one-dimensional
critique every Ava fan has heard of the
past 20 years good storytelling needs to
one are you really trying to analyze Ava
over some YouTube video you watched on
Aristotle's Poetics I never watched
something the thing that makes Ava so
great is how Anno captured his psyche
across a franchise the point isn't to
understand it but to resonate with its
emotion but then why did Shinji and as
long as you cling on to your narrow
perspective because it makes you feel
special for finding a floor in a
masterpiece you will never be able to
zoom out and see what actually makes it
a masterpiece
okay I read Poetics the book called a
cliff notes well I didn't I've even
tried watching the later movies yeah I
should probably get on that
you know once you watch the movies then
you'll see the real ending behind
everything that's over okay so after you
see the new movies it all makes sense
nope